how do you prevent
all the
signatures from collapsing on each other
right because that's a very nice way to
cheat right i mean and you know what
neural networks like to do right they
like to cheat
hi there today we'll look at dynamic
inference with neural interpreters by
walid gondal nasim rahaman and others so
this is again a paper where i will
interview the authors of the paper in
fact we had three of them the two first
authors and francesco locatello as well
so that's going to happen in i want to
say 10 minutes or so if you already feel
comfortable with this paper you please
skip ahead to the interview part it is
by far the best part of this video i
will give a very brief introduction to
this paper by myself right now so
everyone knows what's going on we'll go
over the architecture again in the
interview just because i want to get it
from the authors as well
so briefly this paper takes a new look
at how we build neural networks
specifically it supposes this
architecture called neural interpreters
and these neural interpreters as the
title says they're able to do something
that the authors call dynamic inference
i want to jump right into this what is a
neural interpreter now what we're going
to see in this model is a lot of things
a lot of maybe things that are familiar
are going to be rephrased in sort of a
new terminology and that is because the
thinking that leads to this model is
different the thinking is something like
well if i
process data i'm going to do so in a
series of abstract let's say functions a
series of abstract functional modular
components and what i do is i compose
these modular components in my head or
in the computer when i program it in
order to achieve a certain goal and
we're trying to replicate this in a
neural model this is going to look a lot
like a transformer model but it has a
few intricacies that make it
particularly suitable uh to this to this
formulation and this model here it's not
going to be like the next
state-of-the-art model on imagenet or
anything like this but what it is going
to be able to do is going to be able to
generalize to
unseen data especially in terms of data
that needs some sort of a logic
processing abstract reasoning or
anything like this it's going to be able
to to do this and it's going to be able
to handle things like distribution
shifts or just very little training data
much better than a regular model that i
just train on a training set of course
this model is trained on a training set
as well but
you know what i mean so
we're going to focus on models that
abstractly work a little bit like
transformers in that the input is going
to be some sequence of tokens like a set
of tokens in this case it's a set of
visual
tokens which are going to be converted
to visual embeddings but you can imagine
any sort of token based input such as
text or little snippets of sound or
anything like this whatever you would do
to a transformer currently that's the
same input that this model gets the
model is made up of this series of
scripts what they call scripts and these
scripts are nothing more than just
blocks of computation a regular
transformer also has blocks of
computation this model does as well
nothing special here however inside of a
script now the differences start so
inside of a script where a regular
transformer will still will essentially
only have what you see on the right here
it will have a stack of
attention layers and multi-layer
perceptron layers interleaved with each
other this
script right here it modularizes this
into what these called functions so each
function by itself for example here you
see f3 consists
of
a bunch of these layers
yet there is also f2 and f2 will consist
of different ones of these layers in
fact they do share some parameters but
we'll get to that in a minute so f1 f2
and f3 they are all independent
functions independent from each other
and any token can be routed to these
functions independently so the idea is
that we take the tokens and the tokens
are routed to either one or more or
multiple of these functions but not all
of them the goal here is sparsity so
each token is routed to a few functions
each function takes as input all the
tokens that are routed to it
it internally runs these layers right
here
and then it outputs the tokens again
and what happens then again is special
in that in a transformer we would just
go on to the next layer with the next
set of parameterized functions however
in this case we apply the same layer
again you can see here the top and the
bottom are the same so we do the same
thing with the output we again evaluate
it we route it two different functions
so the same token can first pass maybe
through functions one and two and then
the output is combined from them and
then in the next step we apply the same
layer again and maybe then the token is
routed somewhere else maybe then the
token is again routed to function two
but now also to function three instead
of function one so this is supposed to
represent this first of all modularity
in that we have different functions but
also composability in that we repeatedly
apply the same layer so weights the
computation is shared this is a
essentially a recurrent layer right here
and you can imagine that there's not
only two applications in fact i think
they go up to eight applications of the
same function within one script block
yet the functions they are modular
they're independent from each other and
the
between each recurrent step a routing
table is computed anew note that this is
not the same
routing as happens in the attention
layer the attention layer here is part
of
this so this attention layer here would
be for example right here it would
actually be a part of a function so the
attention layer would only consider
tokens that have initially been routed
to function three so now the question is
how does this routing work and i also
said a little bit that code is shared or
weights are shared between the functions
i want to tackle the second thing first
the way this is implemented and we come
to this all in the interview in more
detail and and i think what i understood
is not necessary what i'm telling right
now what i'm going to tell namely that
these function one function two and
function three they do share some of
their parameters but not all of them in
fact the authors here imagine a scheme
where each function has a global set of
parameters let's call them w and then so
function
gets w which is a global set of
parameters it gets the input x right
which is the token that is
currently being processed and it also
gets c which is the code of the function
so this this here the authors call the
code
and the idea is that
this thing right here that's shared
across all the functions there are
parameters that are shared and then
there are parameters that are just
individual to each function
the idea is as i said the c is the code
and this w right here you can see as the
interpreter
interpreter so the this is an analogy to
you have sort of an interpreter like the
python interpreter that is able that has
code by itself right python is written
in well c python is written in c so
there is shared code among all python
programs but then obviously there is
also individual code for each python
program
they see these functions in the same way
they have a set of learnable parameters
that are across all the functions which
are kind of global interpreter
parameters and then there are local
parameters which they call c which they
call the code
which are also learnable parameters
they're nothing else but they're just
localized to each function and that's
what makes one function different from
another every function here has
learnable parameters with the code
which is individual to each function as
i said it's not necessary like you could
just imagine that these be completely
independent neural modules they will
have independent attention weights they
will have independent multi-layer
perceptron weights um this will still be
the same model
but it's just in sort of an homage to
this thinking of uh of
dynamic computation that the authors
here build in this weight sharing scheme
so the second thing each function learns
by itself it's uh what they call an and
like an s variable i think i believe it
is s
um and this
is what determines which token is routed
where this is a little bit like in the
attention mechanism every token exposes
a key and every token exposes a query
and then keys and queries are routed
according to inner product
here every token is run through
essentially an embedding layer a linear
layer which determines to which function
it's going to be routed each function
has as i said these s variables which
are just
vectors and then we compare inner
products so again each token goes
through this type inference function
which is a
stack of neural network layers we obtain
an embedding t we look at the inner
product between t and what they call s s
is an is a vector for each function and
that determines what's routed where
right this is an exponential this is a
normalization so this is a soft max
routing based so if you have function
one here sorry function one
if you have function two
function three
and you have
your tokens right each token is sent
through the same neural network to
determine its um it's what they call
type essentially it's an embedding right
this is type one type two
this is the type of token three and so
on each function will already have as a
learned or fixed parameter right they
in their model they suggest one can
learn these as well but in fact they
said it works the same as you know
when you just leave them fixed so they
initialize uniformly initialize uh these
s variables this is s a function one s
of function two as the function three s
stands for signature i believe
so the idea here is that the function
exposes a signature that tells which
variables are even allowed to go in the
function
and the
tokens express a type and the type and
the signature needs to match in order
for a token to be routed there and the
matching is done obviously via inner
product so for example these two are
certainly going to be routed together
because their inner product is going to
be large as i said this is not too
different from like attention-based
routing except that this is dynamically
computed however this here is
either learned or fixed so in attention
this would also be dynamically computed
but since the functions aren't dynamic
uh this
yeah this could be a good extension
somehow thinking that the functions
themselves could be sort of
dynamic but then i almost believe we'd
end up kind of at the classic attention
mechanism because maybe you want to
compute the functions from the sequence
here itself right the code and the
routing which would essentially be the
keys and maybe the values not super sure
but yeah so another idea i had just
after the interview is that uh they say
something like you know these these
signatures right here if we want to make
them learnable as well the neural
network could sort of cheat and collapse
them all together so that every token is
routed everywhere which i think due to
the nature of gradient-based learning
would be advantageous at training time
but it's not necessarily what you want
for generalization you would like to
preserve the sparsity aspect for
generalization and they talked about
having repulsion losses between these uh
maybe
one could also take ideas from uh from
vq like from vector quantized vaes or so
they do have the same problem right that
their codebook needs to be
not collapsing and i think the the
quantization procedures that they have
there as well as the methods they use to
construct the codebook could be
instructive for here rather than just
leaving the things at sort of the
uniform initialization in any case this
determines how the things are routed to
the individual functions it by the way
also determines how they are combined
again which is something we didn't talk
about in the interview so the routing
table determines how the tokens are
routed but then also the combination
happens in sort of like the reverse
routing table obviously
because you only want to get output from
where you got input i believe at least
that's what's happening yeah i think so
otherwise i might be wrong here the
attention mechanism inside of the
function happens as a regular attention
mechanism it is obviously gated by
these
c values right here and those are simply
the values we've just computed these
routing values
this essentially just means that every
function only has access to the tokens
that had been routed to that particular
function then there is an mlp after the
attention layer
and the mlp is represented here again
these are all these modeling functions
these are linear layers that as an
additional input get this code and the
code is essentially the parameters that
are special as we discussed before
so they have a formula here for these
mod lin layers and the modeling are also
used in the attention layers in order to
compute keys queries and values so you
can see right here modeling is computed
out of an input and a code vector
it is computed in the following way it's
in a classic fashion it's w
something plus b so it's a linear layer
however w and b are shared across all of
the functions in the same script
then the something right here is the
different part so there's the input but
it's element-wise multiplied by okay
this is layer norm and then this thing
right here
is the code projected through this
linear layer the wc linear layer is also
also shared across functions but the
code is obviously different you can see
what differentiates one function from
the other one is simply the code that is
input to the function everything else is
shared across all the functions in the
same script
this is again not something that is i
believe necessary to the splitting up of
the functions you can imagine every
function having its own independent set
of parameters but it does sort of goes
one step more into this directions that
the authors want to go right here so
then you can build up things so you can
build up mlps as a combination of these
model linear layers you can build up mod
attention layers which is simply a
tension but instead of linear layers to
compute keys queries and values you use
these mod lin layers that get the code
so even in the attention most of the
parameters are shared between the
functions in the same script then you
can build all kinds of things from these
so a line of code is essentially one of
these blocks that has an attention
followed by an mlp which we saw like on
the right side so this
this thing here
that's a line of code
then you get from lines of code
you can determine what is the here the
interpreter which is many lines of code
after one another then you can iterate
these functions as we said we apply the
same function multiple times so the
interpreter now is applied multiple
times right but always always we always
do the type inference the routing in
between and then obviously you can apply
that
many times over and that will be the
whole model so these are the different
scripts that you apply
so here inside a script function
iterations enable sharing of
computational units in depth increasing
the number of function iterations can
increase depth without increasing the
number of parameters so it's a little
bit of a recurrent scheme inside of the
big blocks that make up the entire model
all right that's the entire model right
here i hope you
could sort of follow we go through it
again in the interview so i want to keep
this really brief right here i want to
go down a little bit to the experiments
right now they do experiments on
learning fuzzy boolean expressions so
they have these boolean formulas and not
and or these are fuzzy so they deal with
real numbers and on the other hand they
also look at actual real data so there's
image classification as well as these
abstract reasoning matrices over here
they make some interesting discoveries
for example they can learn the boolean
formulas by only adjusting the routing
parameters oh i've scrolled too far
so by only adjusting the routing
parameters they can learn these boolean
formulas and generalize to new ones
ah i said this wrong they learn the
boolean expression task by training the
model regularly then they can generalize
they can transfer learn to new ones by
only adjusting the routing parameters
which kind of tells them that the
function modules they learned they are
in some way kind of universal they they
represent these boolean functions on a
more fundamental level because you only
have to adjust the routing in order to
make them adapt to new things the second
thing they look at sort of how samples
propagate through the network i'm going
to i'm going to ask them in the
interview about this graphic right here
they look at the inferred type
embeddings and see that really they do
not all collapse to the same thing right
as you can see right here they also look
at how this develops in function
iteration so they say types are more
clustered in the later function
iterations suggesting that the input set
elements gradually develop a type as
they progress through the network they
do a lot of these kind of little
experiments right here on toy data on
real data they even look whether they
can drop out functions or add in
functions
after they've trained uh yeah so that's
that's what they did but i will ask them
all of this in the interview so i again
i don't want to go too much here in
essence i have to say i did like this
paper it is
quite hard to develop a model like this
and then design experiments that really
validate that what you think is
happening is happening and i think the
authors did a good job i'm still not a
hundred percent convinced but i think
that's never going to be possible i
think the authors would would agree with
that statement um it is hard to peek
into these models uh they do test on
real data right here on uh against some
some baselines you can see the results
are kind of all over the place uh their
models is ahead a lot of the times not
all the time though so i think this the
problems are still open and these models
are still out there to be developed if
you have ideas more than happy that you
you play around with it i didn't ask
them if the code was available actually
i'm going to to do that and if it's
available i'll link it in the
description if it's not available then
i'm sorry you'll just have to to guess
around
yeah that was it now over to the
interview
welcome everyone here uh back um very
very fortunate today to not be joined by
one author but actually three i have
with me today uh walid gondal nasim
that all work together on the dynamic
inference with neural interpreters paper
welcome everyone thank you so much for
being right here thank you for having us
thank you thank you yeah
thanks for having us
yeah it's it's
it's really cool um this the paper
because i think it takes maybe a little
bit of a first principles approach to
the whole idea of of
computation it is really framed in terms
of computation it is framed in terms of
i want to have different modules that do
different things uh then it's somehow
being connected with neural networks and
so on uh
can i can i ask you what was your
what was your motivating thought behind
all of this like how did you how did you
get to it did you sit down and say well
i want to build a computer-like neural
network or
what were the kind of leading thoughts
that you would tackle such a problem in
this way okay so um i guess i'll start
maybe so um
so you know like um of course i've been
in bernard's group for i think two years
or more and also joshua and um you know
the the thing that they've both been
very excited about is um
like has to do with principles of
causal mechanisms that's like
you know like that you know you can
decompose the world as a system of
modules that kind of interact with each
other
right so that was kind of like always
at the back of our heads right and then
we thought okay look this is actually
you know the intuitions there is
actually not very different from what we
do as programmers all day right i mean
it's kind of we type functions we use
functions and then we kind of recompose
stuff and it's it's maybe it's not as
different as we think like these two
things are maybe not very different
and um
and then of course uh
since we're deep learners you know like
how do we mash these three things in and
make something cool out of it
so i think that was kind of the
i think the initial
motivation that kind of
drove us to it i don't know i mean
i mean i guess we had like this chat i
think uh
like uh and then we were like okay this
does not sound too shabby like uh yeah
yeah and
i just i have to say like i read the
title i read the the abstract and i
thought to myself like this is such a
banjo paper uh like this is like joshua
banjo has all over it and then i and
only then i looked at the author list
and i was like
of course
um it's it's it is astounding so maybe
you know i wanna i wanna get uh with
i've i've i've you know um
by the time people watch this i will
have done a little intro but i maybe
want to go with you again just briefly
over sort of the the main structure of
all of this so this your your method
essentially takes the form of let's say
what we would know nowadays as a
transformer network just broadly right
so you have a bunch of like input tokens
like down here in this case you do
multi you can do multitask
classification that's why you have like
multiple cls tokens but you could
imagine anything let's say a transformer
network could do as long as it sort of
takes a set of inputs and it outputs
like a set
of of outputs and every every layer as
in a transformer will take a set of
embeddings presumably and output again a
set of embeddings so
so far so good but then here is the
first thing that's that's kind of
different so you your
your model whereas a transformer is made
up of multiple
i guess they call them transformer
blocks
your model is made up of multiple of
these scripts what is kind of the high
level idea what is a script
so
a script
is i mean you can think of it as
essentially like a group of layers
like the the core of the architecture
truly are like the functions
and
uh and the objects because we i really
like this this analogy with programming
languages where you have objects that
are processed by functions
and then when you have a bunch of
functions you stack them together into a
script
and and then you can compose a hierarchy
of scripts so the this split in scripts
is just a convenient way
to share parameters in different ways
across the architecture because maybe
the early layers want to do things that
are slightly different than the later
layers and since the
all the functions within a script share
certain parameters then then you you can
have a differentiation this way
okay so the this is this is simply
because this is the script three is
independent from script two script two
is independent from script one and so on
uh yet within the script certain stuff
is shared
okay so it is okay um then within a
script right you have these what you
call functions and we see right here
there are three functions in this
example uh they appear multiple times uh
they
they're sort of functions next to each
other there are also functions one after
another uh can you maybe comment a
little bit what are what are functions
and and how do you sort of stack and
combine them
right so we could think of functions as
like really the
fundamental like
in this case like a building block of
like it's it's an abstraction of course
right but it's kind of like a building
block it's kind of
a unit of computation that can be shared
and how is it shared it's shared along
depth
right so you see like you can have a
token that goes to f3 and then it may
come back to f3 again or it may go to f2
depending on how it's routed
right so uh so you know like there's
this
reuse of parameters like a dynamic reuse
of parameters and you actually learn how
to reuse the parameters and the whole
function abstraction is kind of is what
enables that
right so uh along with it's kind of like
like horizontally it's kind of
essentially a way of adding more
capacity you can think of it that way
right and horizontally sorry and
vertically it's uh kind of like adding
uh yeah i mean it's adding depth of
course but like it's adding more
computation
uh
more computation exactly and it's and we
have some actually pretty fun results uh
downstairs where we actually show that
this amount of computation is kind of
flexible
yeah even at test time
yeah
you split this up right here on the
right side so this would be this would
be sort of what a function looks like
internally and in fact you have a stack
here uh this stack in depth do i see
this correctly that sort of the front
let's say that the front uh thing of the
stack corresponds to the pink function
and the second one would correspond to
the blue function and the last one
corresponds to the green function so
each function essentially is
a stack of
neural network layers abstractly uh
spoken
parameters right because this
distinction is modulated with the code
of the function again if you if you
follow this programming language
interpretation but you have the code
that determines
uh what the function does
yeah and then to to make it easy then
all the functions actually share
parameters but then they are
differentiated by the code and their
signature of course that determines what
they are able to digest
exactly yeah that's exactly that those
are two things that so you just said
which is one of the questions i actually
had um about you know where exactly are
parameters shared because if anything
this this method seems like a sort of an
intricate way of sharing parameters uh
between things right you just said there
are parameters shared between all of the
functions yes is that correct okay now
what differentiates the functions from
each other is what you call their code
and their signature so if i have any
sort of talk let's let's take one of
these these tokens right here um
so what do i do this is like x
i my token i and i have a bunch of
functions right here every function is
characterized by
its signature and its code and its
signature is you call it s or some s i
believe so s
j and
s determines
whether or not the token is even routed
to the function kind of right so s is
about what the function is able to
process
and then you have to look at what's the
type of your object
and then if the type matches what the
function can process then it can be
processed
so you run a function through this type
inference
function which i'm going to guess is
like a linear layer or something like
this
or multiple layers
you get out and embedding you calculate
the inner product between this thing and
whatever this signature is per function
now i understand correctly that your
framework
suggests this could be learned these
types of functions so every function
would sort of expose a type um very
similar to how in an attention layer
every token exposes like a key
to be addressed right and then whatever
the type inference module expresses
could be interpreted as sort of the
query and you would route queries and
keys that have large inner products
together
um however if i understand correctly in
your experiments you just left the type
signatures at
the initialization so you were happy uh
saying we initialized them uniformly and
that's it that's one way of doing it i
mean even if you don't do it it kind of
still
works but i mean this is just like uh
the
we found it to be i mean we also
experimented with some sort of a
repulsion loss
where we could kind of you know like so
that's so like to give some more context
that was kind of um you know like how do
you prevent
all the
signatures from collapsing on each other
right because that's a very nice way to
cheat right i mean you know what neural
networks like to do right they like to
cheat so like
this
like not learning si is just like one
it's just the simplest way do you know
like prevent this from happening there
we experimented with some other ways
like um i don't know a repulsion term
like a hinge repulsion term right um
that would kind of just push everything
up away if they're
like too close to each other
it worked just as well but you know like
had more hyper parameters and thought
okay how can we simplify this how can we
break it down and then we kind of you
know just froze it and saw oh okay the
performance is not too bad and the
reason we understood was that okay the
type inference can also do
you know like because sis are learnable
parameters but the type inference mlp is
a two-layer mlp it also has learnable
parameters
right and their roles are kind of sort
of interchangeable and to some extent so
uh so so we kind of okay that's like
we figured out there's like one way to
save some complexity essentially
so yeah you you have two things that
essentially are learnable that
whose mission is the same exactly
exactly okay i see
yeah and then you you you do this this
is a this is i think the whole thing is
a soft max then it results in sort of a
soft max there is an exponential of the
inner product and then there is a
normalization involved right so this is
essentially
let's say an attention mechanism over
functions
right because this then produces exactly
yeah
yeah so this determines you have this
nice graphic right here this determines
which token is routed to which function
and the same token can be routed to
multiple functions but
hopefully you've configured your your
threshold such that it's reasonably
sparse so
did you
i don't know did you
was it your
was it your plan to have this as sparse
as possible or what what is the what is
the reasoning behind here i know sort of
the people who argue from from
neuroscience and so on they always argue
for for sparsity only a few of these
modules are activated at any point is it
hard to impose this in a system like
this or or
how how does that work out
i imagine i imagine it's going to be
easy to
like
have one function per token i also
imagine it's going to be easy to have
all of them but to have like a sparse in
between thing is this a hyper parameter
that is very hard to figure out or is is
this relatively easy
so i think like uh we found like a good
range of hyper parameters that which
kind of did the work in and actually
like we have like a whole big appendix
on like how we you know like how to set
up hyper parameters based on the problem
that you're looking for and you know
like the behavior that you're looking
for right because
in the end what you have is a spectrum
right i mean
if you have uh too much sparsity your
thing is going to be really hell to
train
right i mean that's you're doing
gradient based learning right i mean
there there's you know like only so far
you can go and unless you try some
combinatorial magic and uh get it
working so um it's like not a silver
bullet in the sense right but
there's a trade-off between
um
training
stability
uh and uh kind of like sparsity and out
of distribution performance
we found that under some configurations
training went like super smoothly right
and then when we tested it on some
adaptation tasks it was meh
but then we had like when we cranked up
the sparsity like most of the run runs
diverged when we cranked it to the
extreme right but when you crank it a
bit less like on the edge of chaos
that's where the magic happens and
that's where you get these models that
are that perform well in distribution
and are also
um
are also you know like pretty good for
adaptation tasks or the other tasks that
we're also inducted like interested in
due to the inductive wise so it's kind
of always
like playing the daredevil you know like
how far will you go
is there maybe
is given given that this seems to be a
distinct point is there a hope that we
can automatically discover this point um
maybe in the future without having to
set the hyper parameter to be like you
know at this edge of chaos where the
magic happens
yeah so like um
i mean it's that's what hyperparameter
search is kind of about no i mean uh
i mean that's what that's what you're
kind of uh i mean i mean the edge of
chaos is definitely not a new thing i
mean there's nothing pretty pretty sure
there are a few papers on it as well
like it's a pretty common thing also in
neural networks in general so um so it's
definitely not a new thing and um
maybe there's a more principle way that
we're not seeing yet
it'd be cool but i think so far this
paper what we just did is just like
tuned some hyper parameters and it was
not awful right i mean if you did not uh
so if you kind of
even if you did not
go too sparse it kind of worked
right and then the performance you know
like
uh i mean the the less parts you go the
more training the more stable the
training is but uh but but you know like
there is like some leeway
and yeah it's like not an awfully tight
tolerance sorry francesca yeah i like i
think like if you want to be extreme
about this like you could also think
about like
uh you know playing with it during
training right like instead of like
fixing a value
uh you can train the network to exhibit
different behaviors depending on
like you know different type of parts
that you may want to use at test time
and then you you just decide uh later on
okay do i want to be conservative in my
prediction or not
um
whether you know i believe this data is
in distribution or not and then you use
different degrees of sparsity
uh this could also be done we haven't
tried
uh maybe it helps um stabilizing
training because you also allow
uh for like less sparsity also at the
end of the day there is a exponential in
front right so like small values gets
killed anyway
uh yeah
okay yeah that's what i what i meant
like probably one like having having
one dominant value is also pretty easy
uh
multiple may get a bit okay but now this
is this is a the part that
routes let's say the tokens to to these
functions you call it type inference but
in essence i it's like i think it's fair
to just call it sort of
a ten like it's a little bit like
attention based routing um so it's a
soft max over inner products um with you
know with the things that are available
and
the inner products determine sort of the
routing table
um not entirely right i mean it's
so it's not like exactly an attention
mechanism but it kind of this is kind of
like another layer of attention right
it's kind of like if you want to think
of it like a nested attention right very
second attention like the higher level
attention decides which token get to
interact
via
that function in the lower level
right so it's kind of like
a hierarchical attention of a sort if
you want to think of it that way right
it's an attention in front of the
attention because now we actually get to
the attention uh which happens inside of
these functions you've already alluded
to the fact that um there are there are
inside of these functions
um
there is there is something happening so
i i also had a bit of trouble
understanding this just from uh parsing
your
your math a bit but i think what you
said right before help namely you have
these um
you have what you call mod lin layers um
mod what does mod stand for by the way
modif
modulated modulated linear layers of
course
now the modulated linear layer is a
linear layer right which means it's it's
a w or
it's w
times something plus b so there's a
weight matrix there is a bias but the
something in between is a little bit
different you don't only have the input
but you have the input and this is the
um the element-wise product with
this thing right here and okay we have a
normalization layer but essentially
again it's a linear projection of this c
value and so this is wc
times c
and the c comes from here so that's
actually an input to the function now
is it like do i understand this
correctly this here this is a learned
set of parameters that is shared among
all the functions in the same script
is this
that is correct this is what i
understood that is absolutely correct
that's totally correct good
yeah
so and but yet the
this c right here that of obviously says
how one function is different from
another function otherwise
and this w is also shared between all
the functions which one
uh yeah yeah
yeah all the parameters are shared
except whatever x is
element wise multiplied with that is the
thing that's not shared so this is i
think your analogy is that c here is the
code of the function uh that's how you
tell the function what to do and then x
is the input and um the rest is the rest
is essentially
the same across all the functions so you
kind of parameterize
the function uh with its code it's a bit
like a
like a like a touring machine or so
i mean it's it's not a new like it's not
a totally new thing right i mean i think
we cite a bunch of papers as well but
like
they're like a class i mean stylegan
uses something kind of similar if you
think about it right and uh as does sips
uh like conditionally independent pixel
synthesis and like
they serve as pretty strong inspiration
for this
setup right so that's what i mean i
don't
so yeah
i don't think in this part we reinvented
the wheel
yeah sure i don't know
um it's like
there might be other parts
this my question is where does the code
come from because i clearly see that you
know here is you know a token
um the token gets routed to one or more
functions so the talk the x comes that
is the token that is the input now where
does the code for a particular function
come from is that also just like a
learned parameter for each function so
f1 has its c f2 has its c f3 has its c
okay i mean another way to i think
another way to write this if i were to
sort of draw this up is that instead of
drawing this right i can
i can also say well there is
a um
this here is is also just kind of a
weight sharing thing right it's a
learned parameter times another learned
parameter except one learned parameter
is shared across all the functions and
one learning parameter is
separate per function um
so this if we leave away the weight
sharing
part of that it's a set of learned
parameters for each function so i can i
can imagine my x and here is my c that
is
one per function the x and the c
it gets multiplied element wise
and
maybe here is c2 and c3 so that gets
multiplied element wise as well
and as well so the x goes into each of
these and then all of them
uh
individually all of them go to through
this same
linear layer this outer linear layer
which seemed to be completely shared
right this w so this is like w
x whatever comes out of this calculation
plus b
okay so essentially
yeah sorry a good abstraction to think
about this would be like really an
interpreter in python right so that is
kind of like a dodge to the whole name
right because like you may have
different functions
right but
and these functions they have their code
they may do different things but in the
end the actual interpreter that's doing
the computation it's shared between all
the functions
okay right so like so this would be the
interpreter here
yeah like because that's
shared yeah the part that is shared
between the functions those are the
interpreters that's i mean you can think
of it as parameters of an interpreter
so this is this is a way to
i would like it's a again what i said at
the beginning it's sort of uh it's sort
of just a
an intricate weight sharing scheme uh to
to characterize a linear layer this is
it would work independently right the
type inference module would work
independently from sort of the mod
linear layer
uh
these these two could we could make
separate models with either one or the
other
um
yeah so you can i mean if you
so like the x's right i think that's
where
that's where the uh the signatures and
the type inference thing comes in right
so if
if uh you know like if a function c1 you
know like sees x or if it just sees
zeros
like in a implementation right that is
what's determined by the type inference
mechanism yeah right but uh but
otherwise yeah
totally
and that's what makes the symmetry a
little bit right because now we are
sharing parameters in both widths and
depth so i mean it's clearly you want to
differentiate a little bit uh what
happens right and and
and that's how it happens essentially
cool and you use this
mod linear layer which um so
its input and output are as a linear
layer or you input at a token and that
will output another embedding for that
token
and you use that in sort of the rather
classical way of doing attention so you
compute keys you compute queries and you
compute values from the token using
these now these mod linear layers
instead of just linear layers as we
would do it in regular attention and
then the attention mechanism is
essentially the same except of course it
needs to respect that routing table
right that we computed initially so
any any function so the functions here
are essentially attention mechanisms um
yet they only get
access to the tokens that the routing
mechanism determined uh
would be appropriate for for those ones
yeah you can really think of it as a
sparse attention that doesn't get all
the tokens gonna get gonna get a subset
of them yeah
okay so now we have we have the sort of
attention matrix and we can again use a
linear combination here and uh send that
as a classic attention mechanism does
through another linear layer in order to
get the the output embedding of um
of a particular token um
is it
usually in let's say regular attention
mechanisms um this part here takes quite
a lot of parameters which is it doesn't
seem like it like it doesn't sound like
it doesn't look like much right but it
does take like a lot of parameters and
and uh computation does your does the
fact that you parameterize things with
these codes does that uh change
how many parameters there are in
different parts of the model uh can you
save a lot of parameters using these
these weight sharing schemes or
like what what do you is it
is it a side effect of your architecture
that you also have
less parameters let's say in i mean yeah
because they're shared everywhere right
so at the end of the day you have less
parameters it doesn't mean
that your inference speed is going to be
faster right yeah
but
definitely it is a it's a very lean
architecture in terms of number of
parameters
yeah that's just that's what it is
you're sharing it in depth right so
that's kind of the that's where yeah but
you're also kind of not totally sharing
it because it's codes that kind of also
run the show you're kind of sharing and
not sharing at the same time in a very
special way so i think that's kind of
that's
that's the stick
so coming back yeah exactly coming back
to this diagram right here
so
f f1 f2 and f3 they all share
the same sort of global parameters but
then f1 has its own code and f2 has its
own code and f3 has its own code
and
what you do now that's what you said
just now is we apply this layer
recurrently right we apply it multiple
times within each script so potentially
that allows one particular token to
first go through function one i have a
result computed from that then go to
whatever function three uh have a result
computed from that and so on so the
the code for function one would always
be the same um
independent of which step it is applied
so this really feels like i'm a
programmer and i'm composing functions
one after another exactly and then it's
nice because you can do it in a totally
flexible way right after function three
you could go back to function one again
uh
and or or use uh function three again
like it's completely
uh like
the way each example is routed through
the network is completely independent
yeah and and it's determined on a per
sample basis right and and the routing
itself is completely learned
so that's why it's a very interesting
architecture yeah
i see that yeah that's that's pretty
cool um
it is like it is implemented i see like
as a recurrent neural network right i
mean essentially it's i apply the same
function over and over again parameters
are shared across the depth which is
kind of akin to a recurrent neural
network did you did you have to do any
sort of
tricks
in order to get this to run stably or
anything like this did you notice
anything like how how much stacking did
you do in depth how often did you apply
each uh line of the script
oh that's a very very very it's an
excellent question so like um
so i i think we talk about it at great
lengths in the appendix but nevertheless
uh what i
so like what we tried was kind of so
what so we went i think in our the
biggest models we trained were like
two
scripts each with eight
such recurrent layers if you want to
think of it that way right so such
function actions that's i think how we
call them
uh
and
that worked essentially
without much of a problem right and we
tried even some combinations for
instance like two to two which means
like we had two scripts like we had two
scripts
and then two um
two iterations per script
and then um and then there is another
there's another aspect over here which
is kind of how many
you know like inside you know the
uh mlp attention mlp attention you can
yeah yeah so you can kind of keep adding
more to it right so that's kind of kind
of like another hyper parameter and we
found like 22 also works pretty well
like absurdly well which uh this was
interesting and like eight one one also
works pretty well like
eight function activations one script
one
but that's also why you want the scripts
right because it breaks this chain
yeah and allows you to not have a
a chain that is too long
and exactly exactly you can think of it
as a yeah
as a way to break the recurrence
and between the ones inside here uh like
this let's say this mlp and this mlp is
are these the same functions are the
parameters shared or are these two
different
functions that
that now you know inside that live
inside of these functions they're
different
they're they're different so you have
different functions here
that get repeated here
and then
you have different stacks of these
repeated applications of different
functions yeah okay
that's right so the real the real
recurrence the recurrence here happens
in in step number two that's where you
recurrently apply the things and inside
of the function it might take more than
one layer to make the function you know
powerful enough to do its computation
okay exactly that's the right
integration okay yeah and so i see i see
kind of i see
yeah sorry go ahead
um yes there is some lag but i i just
wanted to say i mean we also tried to
increase this recurrence to left 16
and uh i remember it worked
as well like i mean there was no issues
and we shifted from three different
tasks like from multi-uh this multi-task
classification to this
uh
to this reasoning task and the
parameters did i mean
we
kept them the same and they were out of
the box yeah it's a it's a little bit
like so i again i see a little bit you
you combine a lot of things obviously
here um
because i can also think of a regular
attention
uh based transformer where i have let's
say i have that this here as a block and
i just
repeatedly apply the same block i think
the
didn't like the hopfield network paper
or so even make an argument that that's
sort of uh connects transformers to
hopfield network
um but that was always sort of the
entire attention so i can imagine that
by itself i can also imagine what i said
before this routing just by itself in
fact i believe the sort of mixture of
experts idea is very much akin to that
where you say uh this the mlp here as i
said it takes up a lot of computation or
or
and
i can route the tokens sparsely to the
individual
experts
yet you
uh
decide to sort of split up the entire
layer all together and
that
yeah i think i think it
it comes from different motivations
because the mixture of experts obviously
comes from the motivation that i don't
want to uh i want to shard my model
somehow
but that means
that doesn't work super well with
the sparsity that you do in the
attention mechanism but i don't wanna
don't wanna that
but if you think about it if you think
about it like this could also be a
limitation of our approach right because
now every example has its own
independent path to the network and yeah
and now you cannot really
exploit like patch statistics right like
now i could say okay i have this special
examples and they you know they look
like all they would they would all
benefit from this particular
path in the network but you're still
deciding on each of them independently
and yeah
this is the drawback that you need to
keep every expert around
yeah
so if
if i were to describe
your model
without let's say the language of this
functional approach and so on because as
it's that you you introduce a lot of new
words like scripts and functions and
lines of code like there's lines of code
which so there is the interpreter right
and the interpreter goes across scripts
and every script is
wait i had it before is like composed of
different um
lines of code and each lines of code
shares the same functions and so on if i
describe this let's say without any of
the language i would say this is a
transformer like model where um each
each
that is divided into blocks each blocks
is a recurrent application of uh
a
fixed layer of attention mechanisms
um the attention mechanisms are
separated into individual modules that
in parallel can process data and then
you route that data sparsely to these
individual modules that you and you do
this recurrently so
the modules can dynamically process
these these inputs okay
what you did sounds a lot cooler than
than this and i can totally see that you
you know you come from this very
different uh point of view and i think
it gives it gives rise to a very
interesting model so now it came to the
the point where
um
you did some experiments to
validate
this and what is especially interesting
of course is are
your hypotheses what kind of hypotheses
can you even make building such a model
like can you lead us a little bit about
how you approached
the experiments because what's boring is
you know we get better on imagenet also
probably that's not going to happen
right um but
you need to i think this is maybe a
little bit for researchers who are
starting out
when you have this new architecture
where you think aha okay this does
something new how do you design an
experiment that sort of validates yes
that's really what's happening like how
do you approach this yeah so for me like
uh i mean we have three experiments
right um but for me there are really
like the two cluster of experiments
right uh
the one on
more like real data is about
can i solve both classification and
reasoning with the same architecture for
me that was the most interesting part
and
then of course like i want to see all
the advantages of the modular
computations i want to be able to change
the inference time adding modules
dropping modules and whatnot
um but for me the crux was really like
can i do these two tasks that are
seemingly very different
and then the other part on the on the uh
toy experiment it was really about uh
can we truly validate
that
these functions can be composed in novel
ways
because uh when you go about it in on
the visual data for example like i mean
it's really hard to
say exactly what is happening right but
then my favorite experiment is when you
train the neural interpreter um
on uh two like logic rules and then you
can extrapolate
to unseen logic rules that then can be
obtained as a composition right and and
you can do that only changing the
routing then it means
that the network actually did learn some
compositional knowledge which which was
our goal to begin with yeah and so
that's what you did you did here you
took these logic formulas um and you
built you built a data set from them you
know you have and and not and or and
these are all fuzzy so these are not
boolean logic but they're they're you
know
made out of real numbers and there's a
multiplication um
not this is one minus and so on and
you can now build these build boolean
functions you can sample them of course
in some interval you can train your
network on that and now you wonder can
it generalize to unseen logic formulas
which would sort of be
if this works one would think
that the network has learned these
fundamental primitives of logic if i
train like learning and or and not then
i should be able to recompose my
primitives to perform sore and i should
be able to do that without changing the
core
uh the parameters that that decides the
computation but only how you stitch
together the functions that in our case
is the routing
yeah so you yeah you only you only
changed the routing parameters
nothing else of course of course if you
change everything else it works better
but it still works surprisingly well if
you only change the routing parameters
and that was the interesting part
there was this recent paper about
similar things that that essentially
said i only have to adjust the uh layer
norm parameters in order or there there
are also these adapter layers right did
you did you compare to any anything like
this or do you see parallels between
what you're doing and essentially you
know people saying well if i just change
people saying
more generally
i can adapt a transformer if i just
change like very few parameters in
between the layers
do you see parallels or i think the
motivation is different like uh
so there are papers that
adapt for example like the vaginal
parameters uh when you are on a new
distribution right and then you you can
get much better robustness
uh but for us here is really about uh
getting some evidence that the
architecture is able
to
reuse and recompose these primitives in
novel ways
so i mean of course like
methodologically it's the same right
there are like very few parameters that
you want to adapt but the reason why we
do this is completely different sure
but but i think
at the same time it's also kind of
i mean they also in a very different
from a very different angle they make
kind of a similar point you know like i
think the paper you're referring to is
that uh transformers are universal
computational engines or something
exactly yeah yeah i mean i love that
papers i think it's one of my
like favorite
for like since the past few years i
really loved it and um
and i think you know like
the message they're trying to say
send is kind of yeah look if you have a
pre-trained bird it's in some sense it's
universal right because the inductive
biases of even attention is
a good place to start right and this is
kind of
like taking that a bit a step further in
in my mind yes right and you know like
it's actually yeah
you go you go ahead and you say not only
not only should we train like layers of
these attention computations but if we
structure them in certain modular way uh
that might lead to even more let's say
universality yeah
yeah that's it
and another node star i think has also
been kind of like our
2019 work uh the benji hotel uh work on
uh meta transfer
uh
objective for learning disentangled
called mechanisms
and i think the argument there is like
if you have a good modularization
of knowledge
then you know like when you when given a
new data distribution you should be you
should get away
really like easy when it comes to
adaptation right because you're already
kind of have all the pieces together and
when you see a new distribution you just
need to change like do small localized
changes and then you're good to go
right that's kind of also being a north
star as you see like for the adaptation
experiments that come below right that
um you know like
if
if you know like yeah
that also connects with the whole causal
picture in some way right not the
classical causality but the causally
inspired
uh class of uh models that
so yeah i think that's just like another
not start that
has been guiding the hypothesis because
you asked you know like how we came up
with these hypotheses yeah like uh i
think that's one of the
angles as well and like generally like
if you want to connect it back with
causality uh
that that has been uh
like a core
uh guide for my research agenda taking
ideas from from the causality literature
and
using them to the then develop the new
architectures and new neural networks
uh but then really you know there's no
causality test right so
you can only pursue some of the uh
side benefits that you would expect from
from a causal model and this be this
ability of recomposing and using
knowledge
without having to use a lot of examples
right that's clearly one of them and
it's inspired by the paper of joshua
and so that here you you track a little
bit how
tokens uh
go through this computation graph and um
i i have my so just i love this line
here just there are variations but also
similarities between samples in how
their constituent set elements are
routed through the network which is
i was like well what am i supposed to
make of this uh do you want to maybe
tell a little bit what we can see in in
this analysis so these are three uh
different
i'll let you explain it it's probably
better yeah it's a controversial plot uh
i think um
i should take
um so
um a reviewer told us okay so what's the
idea here
to appendix no
yeah your show was like yeah why do we
need this in the main paper like
does it but so
what i see what i see is that there
appears to be you you say you say the
colored dots identify functions right
same color implies shared parameters so
here i see that the same function
twice so these these seem to be this
uh appears
seems to be
one of these scripts and this seems to
be another one of these scripts exactly
and and um um
so then
the func that colors tells me yeah the
functions are repeated okay i can i can
accept that that's exactly as you said
and then i'm somehow supposed to read
something from the line from the
connection line so what you're supposed
to read is that they're not all the same
if you put three samples okay we have
three samples they're routed differently
through the network right so i mean it's
kind of uh putting our money where our
mouth is when we say that uh
you know like samples are routed
differently through the network you know
like this is kind of like a
visualization of that right if you have
three different samples they're routed
differently to the network here it is
and i think here it's important like uh
you don't want to like over interpret
what these functions do on the
visual domain right because you don't
like i mean that's the power of deep
learning right like that you have this
this cascade of computation and maybe
the result in between is not
particularly interpretable and you don't
want to read too much into it and we
also don't want to do that
not to over constrain the network but
then it's important to to really show
like if i give you concretely three
images
yeah is the computation identical
because if it is then we're doing
something wrong right yes exactly yeah
that's what i like this is this is
because i think in these works it's
always really important to sort of try
to uh check yourself right if you're
really doing what you claim you're doing
and i see for example here the first the
first sample has a lot of connections
like in this area and the last sample uh
not at all and so
okay that's that's kind of what i
thought i was supposed to see but i just
wanted to to check in with you and this
is really let's say this is to address
the haters that say uh
all your architecture it essentially it
you know it just does the same thing
it's just kind of uh
okay i see cool and another
another
thing that i want to get to um
is
your sort of claims that now i have sort
of this dynamic i can add functions i
can remove functions and so on do you
could you explain a little bit how do
you imagine that how does that work what
does what do you mean by add functions
remove functions is this during training
can i do something at inference time can
i can i ramp up computation at inference
time
what did you what did you had in mind
and what did you do experimentally so
this is my i think this is my favorite
part of this
model like you know like
so the way you can think of functions is
kind of like i don't know i like to call
it uh smart batteries
right so you can like install new smarts
into your model in like so let's say you
pre-train your so like one angle is that
you pre-train your model on some data
set right and then a test time or like
at adaptation time you realize okay i
want to kind of apply there's a new data
set that i want to apply my model to
right and uh so you can add like a new
function that
like or a bunch of new functions that
would kind of
nest itself in with the other existing
functions and kind of synergize and
work together in order to
solve the new problem right so you can
kind of increase the capacity really
easily because like nothing
the interpreter does not care how many
functions there are right so you know
like paramet like the way it's
parameterized it's kind of
it does not really care and uh so you
can add new functions but what we also
found and i think this was one of the
cool rebuttal uh
rebuttal phase ideas was to um
well so you know like
you can also remove functions at test
time without any additional training so
you like train with five functions and
then at test time you just randomly drop
three of them and the performance oh
like two of them and the performance
does not like immediately tank
you know like it does not
catastrophically fail which is kind of
tells you that right here yeah exactly
so it tells you that you know that the
system is kind of one dropped function
is still fine yeah two two two is
pushing it right
yes
but but it's still not you know like
still not rock bottom but okay i mean
three and four i mean there's nothing
left after three and four right but
but uh
but yeah that's nice right because like
going back to like uh validating your
hypothesis right uh this is something
that uh normally is not possible with
distributed representation and the
typical neural networks we use right and
then you know it becomes important to to
check this even if it you know uh you
can only remove one function if you
remove two the performance is not great
but just the fact that you can do it is
something you really need to check when
you propose an architecture like this
because
it's part of your hypothesis right and
you need to design an experiment to test
it
so when you add and remove functions do
you retrain after you did this or do you
just rip them out and and let and
evaluate so when we remove functions we
just rip them out and evaluate nothing
x-ray at inference time no parameters
are updated except the functions that
are kind of needed so
there's nothing like
no extra training at all the model is
also not trained with function dropout
which is something one could arguably do
but we don't do that i mean the model is
trained with all functions and then it
still kind of
yeah i think it tells us that the
functions are kind of a little bit
autonomous and they can kind of like
yeah like they're not yeah somehow
magically they happen to be so which is
kind of cool and when and when you add
functions
let's say you have a bunch of
pre-trained model then you need to sort
of fine-tune a little bit
um in order to okay in order to
incorporate that do you have i do you
have extension ideas to to this maybe to
make it fully modular that i can you
know grab together my functions of
different models or is this is this
anything you have on your radar yeah
that that would be kind of i mean yeah i
think that'd be
that'd be nice you know like where you
have like a library where you can kind
of pick out the books and like compose
your own
like thing that would be nice i mean i
don't fully know how to do it i i don't
know maybe you guys have ideas
um
i mean it could also be probably it's
probably going to the direction of like
architecture search
sorry go ahead
yeah sorry i was just mentioning that it
can also go in the direction of
continual learning so basically you keep
on adding new
parameters as new concept comes in and
keep adopting the previous model like
without losing
or catastrophically for getting the
previous
uh knowledge
so it can go in this direction as well
so we have like a very preliminary yeah
exactly sorry
you could freeze like the codes to some
of the functions right as you keep on
adding new tasks um
and and potentially okay and even like
just having more like diversity in terms
of data sets right
like
you you first had not trained on these
digits and then then you start doing
animals and then you just keep adding to
your collection of functions
and
you you you have the model
you said before you you did it on some
real data uh can we do classification
and reasoning and could you just briefly
tell us
how how do you assess that the model can
do abstract reasoning it has to do with
these matrices right here right yeah
this is like a fun task
uh which is uh
for me personally is surprisingly
difficult honestly
you need to look at this
pictures very very hard
and and detect patterns
and and then
you have
a list of possible answers
and and you need to decide which one
completes the sequence and apparently
i'm not very smart so i cannot do this
very well
uh but uh
somehow yeah neural networks can do it
and it's a really fun task because it
it requires you it requires a network
to
uh
really reason about abstract entities
and relate them across the different
panels so there are some logical rules
that determines well whether
a panel is the correct answer or not
and you know if you have access to the
logical rules it is extremely easy uh
it's like some quantities are constant
or it's the end of
these shapes
but if you don't have this the right
abstraction
it becomes a very difficult task and
it's really nice that your networks can
do it and especially they can then
extrapolate to to new
uh relations that have not been seen in
the training set and and that's the
of course the performance is is bad
uh
at least compared to like the
indistribution performance but the fact
that it's not completely random it's
pretty nice
yeah
and do you have any
any way or idea i haven't seen it in
this paper but any idea of how you could
train a network on this and then sort of
inspect these functions and really
see that these logical rules are somehow
you know learned by these individual
functions
in some way because essentially that's
what you would hope happens right that
somehow these functions they learn these
individual modules learn to represent
these individual independent i'm going
to guess the data set makes it clear
that these are independent logical rules
is there any way you could think of to
inspect this or is like how it won't how
would you
go about this
i mean you can try to look at circuits
um like the antropic ai style which i
find absolutely fascinating
but you know like but it also shows how
much energy that takes
right so you have like really a team
working like as soon as you have these
distributed systems it's kind of like
and i'm not even sure it even makes you
know like i'm not sure to what extent
these would make sense at all to us
humans you know like
i'm not sure what we'll find there
absolutely right i mean yeah even if if
at all we'll find the same primitives or
not i mean i don't know
and i think that that's kind of the what
makes neural networks so exciting you
know like they might be solving it in a
way
that is like totally orthogonal to how
we think about things
right and uh that's but we kind of made
it at the same time so we're making
something and we don't know
what it's doing which is fascinating i
think that's kind of like
that makes the whole deep learning
journey worth it i think so
sorry i went on a
tangent but but but long story short i
don't
see an easy way
except the whole like circuits line of
analysis which is kind of uh yeah
and we we
excellent is there is there another
thing that you would like to mention uh
regarding
experiments or
regarding um
regarding the paper itself because we
yeah oh yeah i've been talking for for a
while yeah yeah so so like if you go up
i mean a little bit up just the figure
that's just kind of hiding i think this
is also super neat uh figure yeah that
one
so
so yeah so like uh well you had the idea
of kind of
reducing the number of function
iterations you know like instead of
dropping functions we just reduce the
amount of compute at test time without
any extra training like kind of like the
current
recurrent applications of the functions
exactly so we're kind of squeezing in
height and not in width like previously
we were squeezing in width by reducing
the number function but now we're
squeezing in height and
it works
and like i was super surprised to like
uh like it it caught us by surprise i
think like uh so that was that was a
fantastic lead
so yeah just this shows essentially as
you you can you can sort of you train
with eight iteration eight recurrent
iterations but you can get away at
inference time doing seven or six or
even five and performance essentially
stays sort of the same uh it's only when
you go down to one or two that you
really you know really
uh drag the performance down and think
about it of course it's not something
you would
want to do with with this particular
architecture but the idea of uh this
conditional compute and and uh is really
nice because it
uh it allows you to you train your your
your big library
of of functions right and now you have a
task
and and and
inference time is very important right
so okay i'm not gonna do eight
iterations i'm just gonna do half and of
course gonna be worse but i don't need
to retrain anything
or i want to add capacity i plug in this
new module
or i have memory constraints and then i
cut half of them right
this is this is fun and i would like to
see more of eating neural networks
did you try more than you trained with
like
doing 16 when you trained with eight
i think
yeah we we did do that and we expected
somewhat like uh
that it might increase the accuracy not
sure i mean that was unrealistic
expectation and
it didn't do much like it it dropped a
bit
a little
so we did give it okay
so it's yeah
it's fair to say like it works the best
when it is as trained but there is like
there is a
like a variation you can do yeah i see
but at the same time i think it will be
fun to figure out ways of uh you know
like breaking that
pattern you know like not having drop
down but at least you know like
at least saturate that would be nice
yeah right yeah yeah
it might be that if you train with only
like two or three you might have
maybe a bit of a chance because it seems
like just create gauging from the plot
right it seems that at eight even you
train at eight you already seem to be in
kind of a regime where it's you know it
has has done its work right
i enjoyed yeah i enjoyed i enjoyed
reading this and i i very much enjoyed
having you here so same um
thank you thank you so much for being
here and i hope to see you again soon
thank you yannick thanks janick thank
you yeah it was amazing